the jurogan experience but this is
another
one of the really big realizations i had
doing dmt so we should talk about that
okay so
since doing dmt which i did it two weeks
ago i did it twice in two weeks i had
this like overwhelming sense of like
some people do dmt and then they start
seeing people as npcs i've heard that
talked about like they start seeing
people it's like these are not real
people with souls and like
that's strange to me who said that i see
it all the time people's like i've had
friends that do it and they start seeing
people as npcs based on what kind of
trip they had like if they saw the elves
or didn't if they just saw cool colors
or didn't
and for me
wait a minute wait a minute so you're
saying that if people have a dmt trip
and they didn't see the elves and they
think of that person who had that dmt
trip as an and as like an npc like you
don't have like a soul because you
didn't really connect with like any
beings you just saw pretty colors like a
you got a very simple experience you
know what i mean
um but i had the opposite from after
doing a dmt i see so much more humanity
in everyone i'm around like i feel very
changed after doing dmt it's a very
profound experience and like i'm just
noticing more things about people i'm
being more aware of like their body
language when they talk to me and
it's i think it was a very positive
thing doing dmt and my experience was
the closest thing to
a spiritual experience i've ever had
because i've never been a person that's
been terribly connected to like
anything larger than me i'd never been
religious never been spiritual and i'd
say it was the closest to like a
spiritual
thing for me i think it is a spiritual
thing i think it's an undeniably
spiritual thing that's the thing about
it is that it forces you
to think about
love and connection and then the bonds
that people have with each other in a
way that you don't get from anything
else the the the the powerful experience
of a transcendent psychedelic moment
is uh it's not like anything else you
experience in life other than maybe like
a near-death experience
but you could argue that they're the
same thing i know people that have had
near-death experiences that swear that
it was like a dmt trip i'm sure and
there i think i don't think it's
confirmed but people say that it's what
happens when you
legally die or medically die it's like
you have a dmt trip and i could see that
but it's not confirmed but there's a lot
of in you know there's a lot of evidence
that points to that i could see that and
it in a way made me like less fearful of
death because i was like if this is what
happens at the end it's a great feeling
yeah i'm okay with it going out like
that like it's you just get this for me
at least
when i first
was hitting it and then like you start
to leave the planet i felt like this
intense like set of rings going around
my body like of just warmth and like
happiness and love and then all of a
sudden i'm like in space
and
um and i did see an elf which is what
people call them what they look like
um kind of like a court jester and it
had like slinky
long arms
and it would and it sounds like
crackhead [ __ ] if you've never done
d.o.t no i don't know
a lot of people have a shared like
physical description of what these
things look like one of my most profound
experiences i there was a bunch of court
jesters giving me the finger
just flipping you off they're like [ __ ]
you
like i'm openly mocking me and i was
like what killing your ego
well i realize i take myself too
seriously like as they were doing i was
like i know what you're saying and they
went like this
like chill out that's it i like i got it
like while they were doing i was like oh
i get it i get it
that's the thing is like they
a common experience people who meet the
elves or the gestures whatever you want
to call them
they have like something to like teach
you so for me it was kind of similar to
learning not to take myself seriously
but it was more so don't take life so
[ __ ] seriously trust the process of
life because i'm someone who even though
i like to think i have my life pretty
together i still worry about everything
so much all the time i'm always stressed
out and the elf was telling me like does
everything have to be a fight blair is
everything a war
are you worried about everything like
kind of clowning me a little bit
literally cause it's kind of clownish
like really is everything that serious
yeah and i was like yeah i'll just chill
out
yeah
it was like that simple it's like okay
i'll chill
it's it's good that you can grasp that
and have that experience and learn from
it because a lot of people can't and
that's when they have bad trips
because they try to fight it and they
try to resist no i don't move important
anything and then all of a sudden you're
in this [ __ ]
death spiral that was my mistake with
shrooms
i did shrooms um about a year ago it was
actually when i was evacuating l.a
because the riots went up with some
friends in the mountains let's do
shrimps
and it was my first time doing it and
the person who was
supplying said shrooms basically gave me
a huge plate like this big
stacked it covered it in shrooms and
said eat all of them which is very
irresponsible for someone's first time i
don't know i just know it was a plate
covered show me the size of the plate
give me an example
oh my god so this is like a dinner plate
like when you go to like roost chris and
have a steak yes
yes but it was shrooms and i have never
done shrooms in my life i had no because
until you do a psychedelic you have no
concept of a psychedelic right like weed
isn't anything close to it not even the
same planet
so
i ate all of it
we walked down to the water and then the
whole world changed but the difference
between shrooms and dmt is like to me
with shrooms you're still
on earth even though earth's heavily
distorted and
that's because you have your eyes open
and you're walking around that's true
dmt you leave earth if you were in
silent darkness if you were alone by
yourself in the dark and you were laying
down on mushrooms and you just closed
your eyes
it'd be very similar oh okay that makes
sense to me yeah we were walking around
and there's something about doing it
like we were in this neighborhood in big
bear with all these like cabins and like
i was started getting so freaked out
that everyone was just watching from
their houses and it was me and five
people
um and so we're all tripping walking
back to the cabin from the water holding
hands walking slowly oh my god and i was
like are people looking for people they
probably are look at these freaks
holding hands no yeah for sure
and we were all like social media people
or whatever we were like people are
going to film this it's going to be on
youtube tomorrow wow
be fun yeah i would i wouldn't have been
ashamed it's
it's um not the best idea to do that
publicly a lot of people wind up doing
that they do it publicly and they trip
balls and they walk around or to eat a
whole [ __ ] plate yeah i should have
had one little shroom
that's a good way to start yeah a good
way to start is like one and you get
like a little feeling maybe like like a
duogram
you know nothing crazy before you want
to get into like the three to five gram
like yikes i think it's also very
important to do it when you're
maybe in a good place in life like i
would never want to do it if i was in a
bad place like when i did shrooms half
of my trip was really really scary and
really bad because i was in a bad
mindset like l.a was on fire i was
escaping i felt unsure about the world
um
right before we uh tripped it was like a
news report like trump going into a
bunker as protesters descended from the
white house and i was like let me escape
this i don't i don't think it's good to
use it like as escapism shrooms did
trump have to go to a bunker is that
real i think they i think he denied it
after that but i remember in dc when it
was the riots happening and i think they
moved trump to a safe place i'm sure he
would deny it but
but when i did dmt
um i did it very recently and i'm in
like one of the best places of my life
recently like i'm in a new city that i'm
actually really enjoying even though it
was a tough transition at first been
through a couple of those um
but i'm just very happy so i wasn't
escaping anything i was like teach me
what you have to teach me right yeah and
then the second time it went even
farther but
it's um
it's very bizarre that it's so there
it's so easy to get to it's just 15
seconds away
it's one of the most insane experiences
that a human being could possibly
encounter yeah it's
if that was a if there was a thing that
you could like a ride at disneyland it
would be a mile long
mile long line to get into that [ __ ]
thing right everybody would be like i
want to go on that ride right because
it's so [ __ ] crazy
yeah and just the fact that
i don't know so i had a lot of
resistance towards ever trying
psychedelics for a while because i did
grow up in a household where everyone
was addicted to
drugs and
my brother was in prison for selling
drugs and heroin and all that kind of
[ __ ] right um so i was like i'm never
gonna do a drug but then like
i just see psychedelics a bit different
it's not it's not meth it's not any of
that [ __ ]
they are very very very different yeah
it's a whole different thing and
like
it's really hard to even articulate what
the trip is with dmt specifically
without ever doing it so like people
were talking about the elves and i was
like y'all are crackheads don't tell me
about some [ __ ] hell i'm about to
meet
the problem with the term drug is it's
all it's a blanket term that you could
use for caffeine they use for nicotine
use for alcohol yeah there's a lot of
drugs yeah adrenaline's drug
and while i'm sure it's
possible i can't imagine after now doing
dmt twice i can't imagine someone
becoming like addicted to it oh i
wouldn't know about that i know a guy
was a tattoo artist that was doing dmt
every [ __ ] day multiple times a day
and then finally the entities had to sit
him down and go hey [ __ ]
stop stop like you're gonna lose your
grip on this world wow yeah they
literally literally told him to stop
doing it he said see it's such an
intense experience for me that i
couldn't imagine
wanting that every day it's kind of like
i did it and i'm good for a while this
guy's an intense guy that's [ __ ] nuts
he's a wild dude he's uh an artist who
does uh biomech tattoos you know that
biomech type of art you know what i'm
talking about
biomec see if you google like bio mech
art
my buddy has a sleeve done by this dude
his um his art's incredible
oh okay that makes sense but his is more
like that like that exactly like that so
it's like almost like alien that's cool
yeah like that kind of [ __ ] that's
that's a certain certain style of
tattooing called biomech and this dude
was [ __ ] he's well he is still elite
at it
that's a cool thing to specialize in
that type of tattoo yeah that's a little
different that's not quite that's more
like it that's more like it that kind of
it's all this weird sort of alien
looking
[ __ ] trippy i would imagine you have
to be an intense guy to even know how to
do that so yeah well it's also to
specialize in that one particular style
of art it's like his
vision of life was like all [ __ ] up
and distorted and twisted
yeah one of the people i did dmt with
wasn't told to like not do dmt anymore
by the owls but was told like you know
you don't have to come back anymore
almost in a gentle way like we came out
of our trips and the friend was like
they told me i don't have to come back
anymore i'm like how many times have you
done it he's like nine i'm like maybe
take a break then i've done it none i've
done it more than that
yeah yeah i think i haven't done it a
couple years though so maybe i could get
back in there and have a conversation
but the like i said the last time i did
it was probably the most intense and the
most weird because when they were giving
me the finger
but it was like it was i've never like
but it's just
i think sometimes what we what people do
and what i've certainly done is you
protect yourself
from criticism or you protect yourself
from
your own
analysis of your your correct and
incorrect thoughts and actions by
bullshitting yourself and one of the the
ways that you realize if you're
bullshitting yourself is like how do you
react to satire how do you react to
being mocked how do you react to people
not taking you seriously do you go ah
that's their prerogative good luck or do
you go [ __ ] them i'm gonna [ __ ] make
a response video oh right you know and
the the aliens or the whatever they were
the jesters and they all had the little
bells the the little hats yeah it's so
crazy they look like a little courtyard
it's nuts they but they were going like
this [ __ ] you
and they were like openly mocking me and
my initial response was hey
and then i realized like oh and they
were like ah
that's it you got it i was like they're
kind of sarcastic oh yeah well they know
you're [ __ ] they know all of your
nonsense they know all of your thoughts
they know i mean whatever the [ __ ] they
are whether they're a part of your
consciousness or whether these are
intelligent entities in another
dimension that you're interacting with
see that is what i've been questioning
since doing this so i was told by
a friend who's done dmt a lot that after
you do dmt pay attention to the real
world and if you believe that the elves
are real beings that are independent of
something created in your own brain due
to the dmt
they'll like send you a sign right and i
was like again crackhead [ __ ] no i'm not
gonna meet the elves in real life right
right so one of the things in my first
trip that they kept telling me was this
is not the end this is not the end they
kept telling me that because i think i
was asking them like is this what
happens when you die like what is this
they said the phrase this is not the end
multiple times
directly after the trip we go to a
restaurant
and i wasn't liking the inner like
there's like a glow after you dmt that
you kind of want to maintain and i
didn't like the energy in the first
restaurant so i was like let's leave
went to another restaurant what was
wrong with the energy the people were
just weird i don't know it's like you
create like a bubble when you do it with
like friends and you're like i don't
like what they might do to our bubble so
then we go to another restaurant and
there's a huge sign that just says this
is not the end on the thing and i'm like
whoa what
and then i looked at my friend who told
me to look for signs and he's like
i told you whoa so i'm like i mean
i'm not saying that i think that they
really are beings i'm going back and
forth between that
you